hey you guys
friday again time for a movie
retrospective
this week uh the vote was almost
unanimous the god of like
this got way way more votes than any of
the other ones this is the 1988
tim burton classic beetlejuice yeah his
old classic one
you know what's crazy about this is that
um i had actually like put this because
this movie's been
in the queue for like a really long time
and i put it in the poll
like a week or two ago and then it so
happened that after i'd already put it
in the poll and after it looked like it
was gonna win i noticed that oliver
harper
had also done a retrospective on
beetlejuice so i didn't i
didn't do that on purpose i'm not like
writing out his coattails or anything i
was just like oh huh
that's the movie we're gonna do and just
so happens that he did one on it as well
but that's okay we can all do movies i
think this is the first tim burt movie
i've ever seen
i think this yeah well it was only his
second away
he did batman though didn't he the very
first one right no well yeah but batman
came out afterwards
after this that's what i thought yeah
yes i think this was the first one yeah
pretty sure
well this was only his second movie like
um his first movie was
his first full-length movie rather was
uh pee-wee's book adventure
um and then this he got this movie like
on the strength of that and then batman
came out there
i saw pee-wee's big adventure i didn't
know he did that so i i so i guess this
isn't
yeah first movie i saw his first movie
peewee
i did too but i think i saw it after
this one okay i saw i saw peewee i
didn't know that that was tim burton
because i saw this in the theater
and peewee's big adventure i didn't see
until later on cable i'm not like a
huge tim burton fan for me i think he's
only got five real good movies
four or five yeah his early ones are
easily his best ones i mean
you know after a while he started his
best one with mars attacks just sorry
i think that was his best well nobody's
going to argue with you about that
honestly
mars attacks blew me away that one
really stands the test of time
this is a good one though too it's all
right this is probably my favorite one
this
either this one or nightmare before
christmas you know what's crazy about
this movie i was thinking about it today
because
i've seen this movie like a zillion
times i didn't even have to like watch
it again
like for this retrospective because it's
i have the whole thing memorized because
i've seen it billions of times
the weird thing about this is that in
1988 the year this came out
i was at the movies i'm pretty sure i
was seeing who framed roger rabbit
i think because that came out the same
year and i
remember seeing that in the theater now
what before that movie started
there was a trailer for beetlejuice
and i did not believe that it was a real
movie
well i mean i thought i was like are
they are they kidding that's like a real
movie like i didn't think that
a big studio would do a movie that
weird-looking with what looked like a
sympathetic goth character in it because
like i said you have to think this is
1988
okay well it's because of who tim burton
was well yeah but it's like we didn't
know that yet because like i said
pee-wee's big adventure was his first
full-length movie and he wasn't really
on my radar
like up until then because i hadn't seen
that i didn't even know that was a tim
burton movie
yeah it was it doesn't even look like a
tim burton movie doesn't it didn't even
feel like one well because they go back
and look at it again but
you know what i mean i it didn't i
didn't make that connection i mean he
had made like
shorts and stuff and he was a disney
animator obviously before he you know
became a film director he had done like
frankenweenie and stuff
but um so you could tell that he was
really into like you know old
creepy old uh you know horror movies but
they gave him pee-wee's big adventure i
guess just because
it was like wacky but he had to kind of
like go with the aesthetic of pee-wee's
show which was like very popular at the
time so i guess they
they didn't really trust him enough to
have him do like his own
vision with it because it had to kind of
stay within the
within the pee-wee world you know what i
mean so he was like that was somebody
else's ip
so so but i find it really interesting
that a movie as weird as beetlejuice
not only got made in 1988 but was
actually like
really like a big mainstream success you
know
like it made like tons of money i gotta
admit when it first came out and i saw
it i didn't like it
really the only thing i liked about it
was winona ryder i thought she was cute
as [ __ ]
she is cute i don't even know who that
was i was just saying that's cute girl
she was very very young in this too yeah
i was only a little i was only like two
years older
i was 16 when this movie came out yeah
so i was like maybe two or three years
older
but it was just like kind of girls i was
dating in high school well and like i
said it's really cool because i feel
like
in the 80s we've talked about this
before like you would see
like punk and goth characters like in
movies sometimes but they would usually
be villains or they you know
put them in negative light you know yeah
so i think this was the first time that
i actually saw a girl that actually
looked like a real goth chick
that sort of acted like a real goth
chick i mean she wasn't a bad guy she
was actually like a lovely person yeah
and just like a regular person and i
think that that's the only time that
that's the first time that i'd seen that
and it blew my [ __ ] mind back in
these days you know you saw goth girls
they were just hanging out at denny's
most of the time depending on where you
were
when they were that age because they
weren't old enough to go to get to the
clubs yeah you couldn't get the club you
couldn't get the clothes they just hung
out at denny's
yeah be a bunch of them but yeah so okay
so the interesting thing about this book
and this is like
how you know my my book review show and
[ __ ] like that this is how this all like
synergizes
what i didn't realize until i reviewed
a novel by a dude named michael mcdowell
who has he's passed away since
but he was like a big um horror writer
like he wrote like a lot of like pulp
horror novels like paperback
originals and stuff like back in the 80s
and 90s
he actually wrote the original screen
treatment of beetlejuice and the script
had kind of been like
you know going around hollywood because
it was like super weird and everybody's
like well this is [ __ ] crazy
but interestingly his first screenplay
was
was not a comedy it was like way way way
darker
like it did have the thing about you
know the couple and then they get killed
in a car accident and then you know
it did have a beetlejuice character but
in his original treatment beetlejuice
was actually like an evil like a
murderer
like a rapist and he was like a demon he
had like wings and [ __ ]
i would have liked it better i think if
it was like that i thought it was too
silly when i first saw it
you know i mean i wanted it to be a
little have a little bit of a harder
edge
but like i said it was how how old i was
at the time and what my expectations
were at the time
yeah i mean over over time the movie
kind of grew on me
it's kind of one of those weird movies i
guess you could say kind of like the
frighteners or something like that where
it's like
it's not a horror movie but it's not
straight up a comedy either
because it does have like a lot of
horror elements to it and it's kind of
like has a lot of drama elements to it
and it's funny too but it's like it's
you can't really place it in one
category yeah you know what i mean and
they just don't make enough movies like
that i
feel like death becomes her kind of a
team yeah like it's kind of like a black
comedy i guess it's kind of mainstream
but it had weird goth elements i to me
it was a little
a little bit too much of everything i
wanted it to decide on what kind of
movie it was
uh you know i think i would have liked
it better if if the tone
this is back in those days like i like
it now but back in those days it had it
been a little bit more like evil dead i
would have liked it more
yeah which that's comedy horror you know
what i mean right but
uh it was i remember thinking at the
time that it was like overly family
friendly
it is but it's kind like i said it's
really it's one of those cool movies
that they didn't really
even back then they didn't make a lot of
them like this
that were you could absolutely take your
kids to see this movie
but it also had like really really kind
of had a dull humor
it had like adult humor and like a lot
of dark humor in it as well it was a lot
of it was about
death and suicide and [ __ ] like that but
it was almost kind of like
and i'm not sure if there were that many
movies like
i guess why tim burton became so famous
was because he was kind of instrumental
in
making this whole goth aesthetic
like making it approachable and making
it like friendly
you know what i mean because like prior
to that when you had goths and punks and
movies they were
almost always bad guys or it was horror
movies yeah so this was kind of the
first movie that made it
like it was you know cuddly
well it was more closer to the reality
than it was you know
well yes exactly yeah exactly that's
what that's one thing that used to
always like kind of make me mad
like in a lot of 80s movies as much as i
love them was that i mean you'd see
[ __ ] like um you know i'm trying to
think of you know like a you know return
to living dead or
um you know what was the one with uh
with angela in it
uh [ __ ] no i can't remember what it's
called but it had like stigmata martyr
had the bauhaus song and everything
it always seems like every time they had
a character like that she was always
like a bad guy
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
somebody was in a bunch of trouble and
[ __ ] got kids were good kids
that's what i mean it's like and that
was like not my experience i said
usually like all the shitty like people
that were always getting in trouble were
like the jocks
yeah yeah they were one dude they were
the ones doing all the drugs i mean the
goths were at home like reading oscar
wilde and [ __ ]
in my experience drinking coffee at the
[ __ ] counter
at [ __ ] denny's pretty much waiting
to get old enough to get into the club
yeah that's that's essentially what we
were all doing we were just like hanging
out reading books and
listening to music in our room that's
what we were doing down by the riverside
maybe [ __ ] you know with the jam box
yeah yeah so i kind of like that they
that they portrayed her and like i said
i think when i was 16 years old it was
really cool to see that because
i felt like prior to that everyone just
kind of thought you were a weirdo but
now like everyone just kind of like
they're like oh okay so she's just like
a regular person because i mean she's
like
she's not only just a regular she's like
the really kind of the best person in
the movie because
she's the person that she was like the
honest one
well she was the hottest one but also um
she was the only one at first that could
see
the maitlands that could see the ghosts
because she was like open more open to
experience than her
horrible like parents her parents
weren't terrible people they were just
like
really self-absorbed i guess yeah and
like just worried about their status it
was
not upper middle class yeah yeah yeah so
it was just kind of like that they
weren't like
mean to her or anything like that but it
was just they were kind of neglectful
they neglected
what the joneses were thinking right and
they didn't really like get what like
her deal or anything but it's like
so the fact that she you know comes to
this house
and you know finds
surrogate parents really like in the
ghosts
and also like i said i like that it you
know it kind of made death
seem like not so scary or it was almost
had
like an anti-suicide message too because
you know lydia
she you know she was kind of like
suicidal for time because she was very
isolated she wasn't you know her parents
weren't giving her a lot of attention
and things like that
and then once she meets the maitlands
who are dead in the house
um she wants to die to join them
but i think they were able to show like
very effectively but also in kind of a
fun way
that the two of them being dead it's
like they had all kind of [ __ ]
problems
too and like death was like this big
like bureaucracy
and [ __ ] like that what's funny is at
the time that i saw you know i was maybe
a year out of high school
most of the stuff you're talking about
those angles were beyond me then i
wasn't old enough to really appreciate
that you really don't really
get the full you don't really understand
the full message until you really like
in
your late 20s early 30s then you start
understanding the messages in this
movies like what you're talking about
death being a bureaucracy i really
didn't see into that you know what i
mean
at the time at the time i i just
i i couldn't see that deeply into the
message
yeah yeah i mean i was a kid so it's
just i was looking at it just
superficially i was like why isn't this
more scary
but that's what guys are we getting at
that age you know
but over time over time over time
you know i kind of grasped what the
deeper meanings of some of these
messages were you know
i was reading like an article about this
movie and i kind of laughed about it
because
um it was basically saying i think it
was on gizmodo or something
where it was saying that one of the
biggest villains of this movie is like
modern design
because there's like a really big thing
where you know the maitlands are very
like
you know old-fashioned you know what i
mean they're very country they're like
you know they're supposed to be i guess
it's supposed to be connecticut it was
actually shot in vermont from getting up
close enough
and um they they like very old things
very simple things antiques and things
like that and then when the dietzes move
in
they just like they want to tear
everything out they tear everything out
and like they put like all these like
crazy sculptures
i will admit i liked the house either
way like i'm not
you know a big like because i like like
old school looking [ __ ] but i liked the
modern [ __ ] too
yeah but you know what all the stuff
that they this the modern stuff that
they put in there did not age well that
[ __ ] was only yeah yeah really
that was really hip back in the late 80s
yeah
i mean the only thing that that was
missing was a damn patrick nagle because
that was [ __ ]
uh that had already i remember everybody
come on out of style by the time [ __ ]
well yeah because
i i feel like yeah because that was like
more early today
but what did duran duran were putting
yeah but what they were putting in
there was basically like 1988's version
of patrick nagle paintings
yeah yeah yeah so you know that [ __ ]
didn't age well either but i really look
like damn [ __ ]
retail decorations like from halston and
[ __ ] chanel for the time
that's yeah that was the [ __ ] color
palettes and the design
that retail was going for i mean it was
supposed to be
like new york and [ __ ] sophisticated
yeah it was supposed to be like suit
like avant-garde because that's kind of
like
what you know what lydia's stepmom's uh
you know
thing was what she was supposed to be
but but but the joke in the movie was
that nobody wanted to buy her sculptures
because they were terrible and ugly
um even though i thought they were kind
of cool but you know what i mean it's
like but i liked the house you know the
old way too so i kind of like
you know but um yeah so that just the
fact that the dietz has come in
and just like bulldozed over everything
that the maitlands had spent their
life building and like you know yeah and
it was a victory it was almost like a
victorian house yeah yeah
it was totally the opposite the way they
had decorated the inside
yeah like if you like that kind of [ __ ]
why the hell you buying that house
that's kind of one thing that always
bothered me about that maybe i'm like
why didn't you just buy one that was
already
kind of why'd you buy a modern apartment
or why don't you just have one built
like to your specifications right
because i'm sure that like you know the
land is much cheaper like where
you know because they were coming from
new york city yeah that's kind of dumb
to buy a victorian
and then just and then just tear it all
up yeah it's like if you're going to buy
a victorian it's because you like that
architecture
and you want to you know restore it good
luck [ __ ]
with your uh [ __ ] central heating and
air yeah well they didn't really think
about that
you can't air condition them and you can
barely eat them
but yeah so uh as i was saying before uh
michael mcdowell who wrote the original
version of this he also wrote the novel
uh the elementals among many other
things
which i reviewed a few weeks ago in my
terms of terror show
um so so originally his script was much
more like a horror movie like um
you know the the maitlands did die in a
car accident at the beginning but it was
like a super graphic
like car accident like her arm fell off
and like her
was torn off and all this other kind of
[ __ ] which they kind of left in
because i think after they're killed in
the accident because they don't like
realize that they're dead yet
and then they come back to the house and
she says specifically
my arm is freezing or my left arm is
freezing or something like that that's a
reference back to the original one where
her arm was torn off
like in the accident and like i said
beetlejuice was not
like um he actually wanted to
uh kill the dietzes
um rather than frightening them out of
the house
and he also wanted to rape lydia
damn other not just marry her even
though that's still pretty creepy and
weird
yeah even though i'm thinking that i
would have liked the original concept
because i thought
i think it i thought it had to have more
horror in it at the time
yeah you know but like i said way it
ended up that's good it's a good movie
it's classic movie i love chase
i appreciate it for what it is but like
i said it's kind of like it's kind of
like death becomes her it's just a
little more fancy
with a cute girl in it yeah you know but
i really
it's good it's good but like i said yeah
well this is probably one of my favorite
movies ever it should be
just because i like one i like the
audaciousness of it i like that
you know tim burton who had only made
one
feature film at this point with peewee's
big adventure which was like a huge
success which is why they gave him this
one
i really love that he just went whole
hog with it like with his vision he just
did it exactly the way he wanted to do
and apparently they didn't give him much
interference which is crazy
um considering how bizarre this movie is
must have some dirt on somebody
maybe i don't know but yeah the fact
that they just pretty much let him do
what he wanted
and it was like wildly successful
because i am telling you how
when i saw the trailer for this i legit
did not think this was a real movie
i thought they were trolling me yeah
when i was 16. i was like there's no
there's no way somebody made that movie
but they did
and it was awesome and then like it made
like all this [ __ ] money with him
doing exactly what he wanted to do
and it wasn't even i mean okay so it
like in 1988
we didn't have cgi really we didn't have
like all the fancy [ __ ] but even for
1988 he wanted the special effects
to look like old monster movies or like
a
kid's imagination kind of so it's like
it's not supposed to look
real like all the sand worms like they
come out of thing like
in the dolly landscape when they go
outside the house um
you know the the snake that beetlejuice
turns into that's like stop motion
he's like i very much wanted it to look
you know not fake like shitty but fake
like not
supposed to be he didn't want it to look
slick or real
or anything like that he just because he
wanted it to like homage
like older movies you know what i'm
saying because he wanted it to have its
own like aesthetic
and i think he did like a really really
cool like a really good job there's no
cgi in that i don't think there's green
screen obviously
but um both all the monsters and all
that other kind of stuff that's all
stop-motion animation
and then the rest of it's all like
makeup and stuff the acting's good in it
too
i you know crazy acting but it's good
i'm gonna say
like i know a lot of people say like you
know michael keaton he's been in like so
many movies and it's like he's just such
a great actor and i've seen him like in
so many
like awesome movies this might be his
best role this might be
my favorite role of his he's great as
batman too i'm gonna say
now he did that well the reason that he
did so well in this was
why he got batman yeah you know who they
wanted for beetlejuice
originally sammy davis jr yeah okay
that might have worked which it might
which might have worked yeah um he was
crazy i think sam kinnison was also i
don't think that would have worked at
all
but um but yeah i think they wanted
sammy davis jr at first
and then michael keaton was he wasn't a
huge star at this point i mean he'd been
in like mr mom he'd been in some other
stuff
uh by then but he wasn't like you know
an a-list name
he was just an actor yeah yeah he was
just one of them that was out there i
remember this time period
i'm gonna have to say though man my
favorite one was mars attacks and then
out of that i'd put
batman and then maybe underneath batman
the nightmare before christmas and then
this one yeah i think
yeah i mean this is one of his good ones
but i think as he went on
i think he got better but the um batman
with michael keaton that's [ __ ]
fantastic i love that movie
yeah i think that's a pretty universally
loved movie but i think this one is too
i don't think i've ever talked to
anybody that did not like beetles how
can you not like beetlejuice
it's delightful now i want now now one
movie i did want to see
from burton was i wanted to see that
superman with nicholas cage
he was making superman did you know that
yeah i saw some of the
stills and stuff from that it would have
been [ __ ] crazy
oh yeah he had a like a crystalline suit
yeah this crystalline superman suit this
is [ __ ] weird man i want to i wanted
to see that one
that's the thing i this just it reminds
me of just such a time when
tim burton was just like bursting with
creativity because i feel like as he got
older and that happens a lot with like
directors and stuff
when she kind of get older he get burned
out he kind of got into like
a little bit of um you know a rut
with because everybody's like was a tim
burton movie so you know what you
expect you know it's gonna have [ __ ]
johnny depp in it
yeah well i'm kind of glad that like
this was pre the johnny depp
era you know what i mean i dip in every
one of his movies because michael keaton
like crushes this role he got it exactly
right
it's like i feel like because he had to
come across i mean if you think about it
from an objective standpoint he had to
come across as
he basically wants to marry a
a 16 year old girl however old she was
supposed to be and this might she
was really 15 or 16 when she shot this
um
so he's basically taking a child bride
and he's also like kind of a pervert
like he actually does grab like gina
davis's
crotch at some point like and makes a
hogging noise or whatnot
or i think whoever does it to one of
them he's a ghost so yeah so he's kind
of like
so he's he's shown to be like a pervert
but
the fact that he's still like kind of
lovable even though he's sort of a bad
guy
you know what i mean but then he's not
like an irredeemable bad guy he's more
like a trickster
i guess because he does actually help
um you know at the end when they do the
seance when they don't know what they're
doing and then like they bring the
maitlands back and they start like
decomposing
he does actually help them although he
helps them
you with the condition that he'll that
that lydia will marry him he's an
he's an extra dimensional supernatural
being you can't hold him to the same
[ __ ] mories of
i guess of a person he's gonna do what
he wants to do
he doesn't care if it's wrong that's
your opinion
his eight he's out probably outside of
space time too so he
doesn't have an age as you know it i
would think yeah it's interesting to me
too whatever age he
well in the whole in the whole universe
of this movie because i mean really i'm
glad that they never because i know that
they were talking about making a
sequel to this i mean they had been
talking about making a sequel to this
like since
it came out and was like a big success
but the sequel they want to do i don't
know if this is a joke or not but the
sequel they wanted to do was like
beetlejuice goes hawaiian or some kind
of [ __ ] because
tim burton thought it would be really
funny to do like a hawaiian surf movie
like with the whole overlapping of the
gotha said he's like because those two
things don't go together so it was
really funny to him
but i'm really really glad that they
didn't do it because i feel like this is
a standalone
movie i know they did the cartoon series
which was actually quite good although
they changed some things
made like lydia beetlejuice like friends
that went on little adventures or
whatever
but i you know it's like i feel like
even though
there's like a huge expanded
universe that you could explore like the
afterlife
with like all the bureaucracy and like
all
the people looking different
like because some of the people that
were dead
like in the afterlife like the dude that
was in the office that had got run over
by a car or something like that and he
was still flat and he had like all the
[ __ ] you know tire tracks all over
him you know like the guy that got his
head shrunk
um you know the the guy that died in bed
of smoking and he was like all little
and shriveled and ash and everything
and the and the magician's assistant
that got cut in half
like all that kind of stuff but then the
maitlands still looked
the same they look the same as they had
when they were alive
they could change their appearance like
if they wanted to because like when they
pulled their face off and [ __ ] like that
but i wonder i was like watching another
analysis of this and i wonder if they
made them look the same
because they were trying to show that
they were like
i don't know like the most pure
characters because they didn't have like
any artifice they didn't have any like
bad in them so
nothing lingered on like their
shittiness because they didn't have any
like it didn't linger on after because
like i said a lot of the other dead
people like
looked because look at what beetlejuice
looked like he looked like [ __ ] crazy
with the [ __ ] hair and he had like
mold all over his face and
like his teeth were all [ __ ] up and
everything like that so gold on his face
yeah it was like all that dark circles
no it was like he did it was like dark
circles there but it's like all
around the outside like the his hair and
stuff that was all moldy yeah i guess i
forgot
yeah so he so he was like all like
crusty looking kind of
yeah um i also want to i also want to
mention too
i think this might be play somebody
correct me if i'm wrong this might be
the only pg movie it's not pg-13 it's pg
that actually has the word [ __ ] in it
and i don't know how like the mpa didn't
get because usually if it's pg-13
i think you can get by with one maybe
they missed it
i think they missed and it's it's crazy
that they missed it because it's like
it's very clearly
you know beetlejuice enough to go a nice
[ __ ] model
and then grabbing his [ __ ] crotch i
remember hearing i remember hearing
something that there's a
documentary about the rating system that
kind of came out a couple years back and
they said there's a lot of arbitrariness
and politics involved in the ratings
then
it's not a [ __ ] exact science well of
course not i mean anything
that's you know has to do with how
humans perceive
things um is gonna have like differences
because some people like you know it's i
can watch a horror movie and think it's
not that gory
but if somebody is like not really into
horror movies or doesn't really watch
them or whatever they might think like
something
is gory that i don't that doesn't even
bother me or doesn't even register
so i do feel like there's that kind of
thing going on too
but yeah so i mean there are just so
many
classic [ __ ] scenes from this [ __ ]
[ __ ] i mean like i said the whole scene
of them
in like juno's office where they like
pull their faces off the whole like um
scene around the table with the [ __ ]
with the
harry belafonte song and like the
[ __ ] shrimp hands coming out of the
things and knocking everybody back and
[ __ ] like that
it's just i i just still can't believe
to this day and this movie is like you
know 30
something years old now i can't believe
that this movie got made
and that it was actually like a big
success because it really
seems like one of those movies like i
said kind of like the frighteners
but the frighteners was not really
wasn't didn't have like a lot of
mainstream success at the time and even
now it's still kind of like a cult
classic
you know whereas beetlejuice was
immediately it came out and everybody's
like oh yeah and like everybody saw it
and then it
immediately like became this huge
cultural phenomenon so much so like i
said that they did like a four season
cartoon
show um just a couple years ago they
started doing like a there's
like a [ __ ] broadway musical of the
[ __ ] it's like everybody
knows beetlejuice like if you wear a
black and white striped suit and stick
your hair up all crazy
everybody knows who the [ __ ] that is
even and if you
do quotes from it everybody knows what
that is the thing with the frighteners
was the timing
i mean yes i saw it and i saw it in the
theater i liked it
and the theater was just [ __ ] empty
all right
and i remember telling people i said hey
man there's a good i just saw a good
movie it's called the frighteners and
they're like oh yeah then yeah more of
that
people were kind of spoiled with those
kind of movies yeah
you know the comedy horror type
movies there's a lot of that had been
around for a while and people
kind of consider that to be kind of like
old hat
yeah you know what i mean like a tired
genre and
i thought it was like just classic
american cinema
kind of like back to the future but i
think that's
part of the reason why that movie didn't
do well they were kind of sick of those
movies at that point
maybe that's what it was yeah and i
don't know it's just interesting to me
that like
that you know then beetlejuice came out
i mean frighteners came out later
i guess that was 90s right yeah
frighteners was kind of like the last of
that kind of that
all-american steven spielberg kind of a
tone like you know something happened in
american suburbia type of deal
yeah and it kind of had that feel even
though it was a dark slant on it
you know yeah you know
actually i'd i'd put i'd put frighteners
above this movie and i know that this
movie is a [ __ ] classic you know i
mean it changed a lot of [ __ ]
but out of the two i enjoyed frighteners
a lot better
that's just my person that's my that's
my opinion yeah yeah yeah
i mean i like the frighteners too but
it's like this movie like i said this is
probably easily in my top 10 top 20
something like that
and there's two cuts to the front
there's two cuts of the frighteners i
like the long cut
of it yeah shortcut is not quite as good
but and that's the one most people see
is the shortcut
yeah another i think it was the
theatrical release i like the director's
cut of it
yeah my blu-ray has them both the
director's cuts even better than the
than than uh than the theatrical release
but like i said just my opinion i like
that movie
that movies got us a lot of stuff in
frighteners and i like the tone of that
a little bit better than this one
although i do understand why this one is
important it was an important movie for
its time
well in this one it this one kind of
like creates its whole
world and it creates a world that i
don't think anyone had really seen
before at least no one in the mainstream
and kind of like brought you into it
like i said it was dark
it was about death like i said they even
made
jokes about suicide look at like miss
argentina or whoever it was that worked
in the um
in the you know office like in the
afterlife
and uh you know and she was telling them
she's like oh you know death is very
personal it's like you know that's what
happens when they die and they look like
that
and then she said if i'd known what i
know now i wouldn't have had my little
accident and she showed her wrists and
that her
she had slit her wrists and this had
like made uh
you know this was a reference to
something that one of the living
characters had said before that it's
like i heard that if you commit suicide
that in the afterlife you become a civil
servant so it's
so everything's kind of like reacting
back to it so the fact that they could
put like such dark humor
in there and still make it not still
make it kind of family friendly i guess
i mean i guess for little little kids
it'd probably be kind of scary because
there is like kind of some scary like
imagery in it i suppose
but i the fact that they could strike
that balance like so perfectly and make
it
more like charming and heartwarming even
while it was talking about death and
suicide and
you know had like a lot of dark themes
to it
is really like amazing that they were
able to pull that off i mean if you'd
have read the script
it's like i feel like it shouldn't have
worked
you know what i mean but it's just
everything they had the right director
they had the right art director they had
you know all the right actors like
everybody in it is like completely
perfect i have to to like give
[ __ ] props to catherine o'hara as you
know the stepmom because she is [ __ ]
hilarious in this
she's hilarious and everything but um
she's especially funny and this one is
just like this [ __ ]
like artist type that wants to like tear
up all the [ __ ] and i love how she
does these kind of like total like
meltdowns and then she just
totally goes back to being calm again
it's like that just like [ __ ] cracks
me up so much which i guess she did a
little bit of that in home alone too
but yeah so i i would be very very
shocked
if uh anybody out there had not seen
beetlejuice
at this point um but if you haven't what
the [ __ ] are you been doing um
you really need to see it it's it's just
a delightful delightful film it just
takes you on this whimsical adventure
it's i feel like the same way about this
one that i feel about like willy wonka
like the original one not like the
tim burton remake which was terrible but
it gives me that same
like just sense of wonder you know what
i mean
it has that same kind of like aesthetic
to it but still like with a dark
underbelly that is but like i said it's
still it's it's heartwarming though
that's what's so cool about it it's like
and particularly lydia's character who's
like kind of the heart of the movie
and how she kind of like she gets like
the best of both
both worlds at the end because at the
end you know they figure out like the
living and the dead they can live
together they can live in the same house
you know the the dietzes can have their
crazy like modern new york [ __ ] on one
floor
and the maitlands can have their really
nice antique stuff on the other floor
and lydia can just go back and forth
between them and now she has like two
sets of parents one set is
alive and once that is dead and she's
clearly like doing a lot better
and so i just think that's really like a
cool it's just like a cool message to
the movie and it was just like a cool
look to it
and uh yeah it's easily easily one of my
favorite movies of all time and i'm
really glad we got to talk about it like
i said i'm not ripping off oliver harper
i didn't know that he was gonna put up a
retrospective on it but go watch it
because he goes um
his retrospectives are like really good
because he uh goes
like way into like all the background
stuff he's like into the score
he talks about the video games that were
based on it because there were several
um that came out after oh i have to say
the score too i used to have
on cassette and i used to play it all
the time with the danny elfman score and
then all the harry
belafonte songs and everything um yeah i
really really if you haven't seen this
movie go ahead and see it
if you if you've seen this movie but you
haven't seen frighteners i want to give
a shout out to frighteners too
frighteners is similar to this in a way
uh the tone is more um back to the
future
it has that tone imagine if back to the
future was a paranormal thriller
michael j fox plays a paranormal
investigator who's
a psychic but he's kind of damaged he's
kind of a dark version of marty mcfly
and then uh weird [ __ ] happens he's got
a bunch of ghosts that work for him it's
a good flick it's good
it's funny though and if you can get the
long cut version get that one i think
it's the better
it also has a guy from uh uh uh
rihanna made her it was jeffrey jeffrey
comes jeffrey combs plays a
does a fantastic job in that movie uh
playing a
fbi agent what was his name agent uh
i can't remember yeah [ __ ] but that's
also a great movie
i'd recommend either one of them yeah we
we reviewed that a while back
and i like that you mentioned death
becomes her too because this one
similar although death becomes or was
more adult-oriented right
um because that was kind of like about
you know an adult love triangle where
this is kind of more about like a
teenager
and then there's all this other so this
is a lot more like kid friendly out of
the ones that we mentioned
me personally i'd put frighteners at the
top of the heap just because
i think it's a better story in terms of
that there's a lot of like
paranormal stuff that happens in there
that matches up with [ __ ] that i've seen
in my real life you know [ __ ]
out-of-body
out-of-body experiences and near-death
experiences and weird poltergeist stuff
and kind of like the paranormal theme
that it shows
kind of might i think that might be
happening in another dimension to a
certain extent so that's one of the
i thought so personally me seeing it in
the theater with my background
i was tripping i was like they might
know what they're talking about here
because that kind of matches up with
some of the [ __ ] that i saw you know
so uh i think that one was kind of
educational if
or theoretically it was educational
maybe that
some of that stuff might might happen
that way whereas i think they got lee
army the ghost of lee army dressed as a
[ __ ] drill sergeant
in the in the cemetery telling all the
ghosts to [ __ ] stay there to keep
them contained
that was a weird angle that some ghosts
were keeping other ghosts in check
like law enforcement yeah you know i
mean i don't know if that happens but
that might happen who knows ghosts might
[ __ ] police each other
but like i said i think the reason that
i've always liked you know beetlejuice
the better was just because
i think the concept is a lot more
creative and like i said it's i really
really like
the idea of this kind of like
bureaucratic
afterlife and there's all these rules
like with the [ __ ] the handbook for
the recently deceased
yeah you have to like read this thing
reads like i'm not saying it's not a
great movie it is
i'm not saying it's not a great movie it
is a great movie
it's a yeah it's a great movie well no
i'm just saying that i i just find this
is not my favorite but it is great i
just find this one a lot more
like just the concept behind it i find a
lot more like creative
it's just it's just a matter of taste i
wish that i had thought of it
actually like the whole like world
building that they did in this movie and
the fact that this movie is only like an
hour
and a half long and they just built this
whole entire like mythology
about the afterlife i'm gonna say it's
very tim burton
it is but like i said this was before
that was a thing
that was you know he only made one movie
which was not like you know
tim burton really tim um this was his
first
not a bad thing that's not a bad thing
no it's not brittany is not a bad thing
it's just
he just has a very he has a signature
that you can really you can really see
which there's nothing wrong with that i
mean like i said his fingerprints on it
it's just that you know it's him telling
the story yeah i always do
yeah you always can tell like a
different except with that first one i
didn't know pee-wee
the pee-wee's adventure was now i i
haven't seen that for a long time yeah
if i went back and looked at it now i
could probably
probably pick up on some [ __ ] because as
i said you know he had made short films
like he made frankenweenie which was
kind of like you know
yeah like a little black and white like
animated like an old monster move like a
frankenstein movie
so it was kind of like that so you could
tell that he had those kind of like
predilections already
um so but this one was the first one
where
it it seemed like his style just um you
know emerged like
came out like fully formed yeah like in
this movie this was like all
his [ __ ] that he liked and you know
from there it seems like you know
subsequent movies other than batman i
mean batman was kind of tim burton but
he
since that was already a property that
existed
he couldn't really go too crazy with it
he could put like his stamp on it
but i feel like beetlejuice was just him
he's like this is all the stuff i like
and i'm gonna put it all in one movie
you know what i mean because he didn't
have any other like internal
intellectual property another really
good one that he did with and i forgot
to mention it was sweeney todd
i really like tweentop i did as well i
like that one i didn't you know what i
saw in the theater when it first came
out
and i didn't love it the first time that
i saw it
but the second time i saw it i liked it
a lot better i liked the music in it
like
the acting and story was good yeah
whereas i think beetlejuice i just loved
it immediately because it was just like
it was just so
delightful and you know as i said i was
16 at the time
you know really into goth and everything
and i just thought it was so cool
like seeing that aesthetic on the big
screen
and like having people like respond to
it like it wasn't you know what i mean
that was the first time i'd ever seen
that it was kind of mind-blowing so for
that reason alone
um and it's just funny that i saw the
trailer i'm pretty sure that i was at
who framed roger rabbit which is also
another great move man we should do that
one of these days
yeah i specifically remember going to
see that because i think i was with some
of my friends and then i think my
parents
were there too because they took like um
my look my younger siblings to see it
but they were like sitting farther up
the aisle i didn't really like that one
oh i love that movie i didn't like that
one i didn't like dick tracy remember
dick tracy well i didn't like dick tracy
either i kind of
who framed roger rabbit is totally
different than dick tracy it's totally
not that it all kind of came out around
the same time from what i remember and i
didn't like those movies
dick tracy i think came out a couple
years later who framed roger rabbit came
out in 88 the same year that this came
out
um and this was actually it's weird
because who framed roger rabbit was also
based on a much darker
book um but you know they kind of made
it a little bit more
family-friendly although i will say that
i distinctly remember when i went to see
who framed writer
roger rabbit my parents were there and
my youngest brother who i believe was
about two at the time um when
when uh the judge like dips that little
shoe
like in the dip and he's like screaming
and stuff my little brother
screamed and ran out of the theater and
my parents had to go and chase him
like with his little diaper he was like
really like oh my god he could not
handle it
and i still remember like how upsetting
that scene was for him i mean
must've been pretty upsetting for a
two-year-old but yeah seriously
if you haven't seen beetlejuice like i
said what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
everyone needs to see it even if you
don't like tim burton it's still like a
delightful [ __ ] movie
so yeah go see it right now and that'll
do it for this movie review and we will
see you on the next one
bye